ich glaube das ist eines der großen
Missverständnisse auch der Pandemie
Spalten tun nicht die Regeln Spalten tun
Menschen die sich gegen die Solidarität
entscheiden wenn ich in einer
Gesellschaft lebe dann muss ich auch ein
bisschen schauen was meine Entscheidung
mit den anderen machen und das kam zum
Beispiel in deiner Begründung in
keinster Weise vor
[Musik]
13 Fragen hier kommt die erste sind
Nachteile für Menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen gerecht oder nicht
wenn ihr sagt ja dann würde ich euch
bitten geht auf das Grünefeld wenn ihr
sagen eher nein dann bitte auf dem
gelben Feld platzieren
[Musik]
so jetzt wissen wir wo ihr steht aber wo
steht ihr eigentlich zwei Drittel der
Deutschen sind inzwischen vollständig
geimpft und haben damit auch fast
vollständig ihre Freiheitsrechte zurück
Menschen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen obwohl sie könnten müssen dagegen
weiter mit Einschränkungen leben zum
Beispiel dürfen sie unter 2g-regelung
nicht in jedes Café oder Restaurant oder
in die Clubs außerdem müssen sie
corona-test selber zahlen und mancher
diskutiert sogar eine Erhöhung der
Krankenkassenbeiträge ja gut so sagen
die einen denn nur die Impfung hilft auf
dem Weg zurück in die vollständige
Freiheit nee total ungerecht sagen die
anderen denn im unwillige würden
pauschal an den Pranger gestellt werden
das sei eine Impfpflicht durch die
Hintertür und das schade wiederum dem
gesellschaftlichen Klima meine Gäste
sind heute natürlich erstmal uneins die
spannende Frage wird sein schaffen wir
es eine Kompromisslinie zu
identifizieren wenn ja wie sieht sie aus
und wo könnte sie verlaufen schaffen
also diese Damen und Herren heute sich
aufeinander dazu zu bewegen wenigstens
in Teilaspekten jetzt aber erstmal die
Frage an euch wo würdet ihr euch
platzieren auf der grünen Seite ja
Nachteile für ungeimpfte sind durchaus
akzeptabel und gerecht oder auf der
gelben Seite nein auf keinen Fall das
schadet dem gesellschaftlichen Klima
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
das Spielprinzip ist klar denke ich also
wenn ihr der Gegenseite in irgendeinem
Punkt zustimmt dann könnt ihr gerne
einen Schritt auf sie zugehen also nach
vorne und wenn ihr sagt grundsätzlich
finde ich deine Meinung gar nicht so
schlecht aber in dem Fall erzählst du
wirklich totalen Quatsch dann könnt ihr
auch wieder einen Schritt zurückgehen
das heißt ihr könnt hier richtig
Bewegung ins Spiel bringen mein Ziel
wäre es am Ende dieser Folge möglichst
viele von euch hier in der Mitte zu
versammeln im sogenannten kompromissfeld
bei dieser Frage bin ich sehr gespannt
wie weit ihr am Ende hier vorne steht 13
Fragen hier kommt Frage Nummer zwei und
die geht an Erik Erik du betreibst eine
Bar und du hast dich entschieden die
2g-regel durchzusetzen das heißt Sie
dürfen nur genesene und geimpfte deine
Bar warum
ist in erster Linie eine
betriebswirtschaftliche Entscheidung
also ich habe mich die komplette
Ausgestaltung von 2G und 3G ist nicht
auf meinem Mist gewachsen ist ein
politischer Entscheidungen aber die Wahl
die ich hier habe an der Stelle ist auf
der einen Seite sage ich bei 2G ich kann
im Laden wieder komplett voll machen und
bei 3G habe ich die Einschränkung dass
ich nur ein Drittel der Platz besetzen
kann und an der Stelle war es für mich
einfach eine wirtschaftliche
Entscheidung auf der einen Seite plus
alle anderen Gründe die ist natürlich
auch noch gibt ich bin nicht nur
Gastronom in der Stelle der
betriebswirtschaftlich denkt sondern ich
sehe auch noch die soziale Verantwortung
und jetzt zu sagen ich mache jetzt
einfach für alle wieder auf und tue so
als wäre nie was passiert wäre dann
denke ich der falsche Weg ich habe
gerade gesehen du bist nach vorne
gegangen warum weil ich ihm in dem Punkt
total recht gebe und vor allem darin
dass es eine politische Entscheidung ist
und genau die finde ich aber falsch weil
ich kann durchaus seine Lage
nachvollziehen dass man nach all dem was
wir hinter uns haben wirtschaftlich
denken muss
und deswegen erwarte ich von der Politik
dass sie menschlich denkt und diese
Entscheidung nicht an ihn abgibt weil
ich glaube nichts zu Ladenbesitzer
geworden bist weil du Bock hast Menschen
zu kontrollieren oder Menschen aus
deinem Laden rausschmeißen zu müssen und
das läuft für mich gerade extrem falsch
mein Eindruck ist dass die Gesellschaft
gerade sehr gespalten ist und das muss
aufhören wir müssen miteinander reden
und vor allem müssen wir einander
zuhören meine Erfahrung ist dass die
Gespräche die man führt meistens darum
gehen dass jeder seine Argumente los
wird und den anderen Versuch zu
überzeugen weil er selber hat ja Recht
aber eigentlich ging es darum der
Gegenseite mal zuzuhören und das ist
mein Großer Vorsatz für heute denn ich
glaube dass wir schon auch gemeinsame
Nenner haben ich halte fest es bewegen
sich viele Menschen schon in Richtung
Mitte und das nach zwei zwei Sätzen das
ist toll schön zu sehen Lutz Erik sagt
er macht 2G auch aus einem gewissen
wirtschaftlichen Zwang heraus du sagst
du würdest gerne drei g machen darfst es
aber nicht als Sprecher der Club
Commission das heißt wenn du für die
Clubs in Berlin sprichst sondern du
musst mit zwei g Leben warum findest du
das problematisch
wir haben uns für 3G ausgesprochen weil
wir nach 18 Monaten Stillstand inklusiv
sein wollten wir wollten wieder
Nachtleben für alle bieten und nachdem
jetzt auch jeder impfangebot hat so
nachdem wir auch die vulnerablen Gruppen
Schützen konnten glaube ich ist dann
irgendwie auch der in der Zeit dass wir
sagen jetzt kann auch jemand selbst
entscheiden selbstbestimmt entscheiden
ob man sich dem Risiko aussetzt und
dafür würden wir natürlich aber noch
trotzdem verlangen dass man sich testen
lässt das ganz wichtig Clubs sind ganz
wichtiger gleisse in der Gesellschaft
sie bringen Menschen zusammen in einem
Kontext wo man eben auch Leute trifft
die man vorher nicht gekannt hat in
einer sehr lockeren Atmosphäre und das
ganz wichtig dass wir da nicht schon
wieder eine Trennung herbeiführen
zwischen Menschen die das dürfen und
Menschen die es nicht dürfen und ich
wünsche mir einfach dass wir da jetzt
ein Stück weiter kommen und den Menschen
wieder mehr Verantwortung geben und sie
selbst entscheiden lassen
jetzt ist Elke ganz weit nach hinten
gerannt warum ein Test schützt nicht vor
Corona jeder der getestet ist schützt in
erster Linie mal die nächsten zwei bis
drei Stunden seine Umgebung nicht länger
der Test gilt aber in der Zwischenzeit
nur noch 24 Stunden davor 48 Stunden im
PCR-Test jetzt 48 Stunden da vor 72
Stunden ich habe in der Praxis Patienten
erlebt die 48 Stunden nach PCR-Test eine
vollausprägung von corvit hatten die
eindeutig infektiös waren die mit diesem
Test der 48 Stunden davor getätigt wurde
aber in jede Bahn in jedes Flugzeug in
jeden Club gekommen werden und von daher
sage ich in Test ist nicht gleichwertig
mit einer Impfung die Beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte sind meiner Meinung nach
gerechtfertigt da ungeimpfte sich selbst
nicht schützen sondern auf die
Solidarität der geimpften hoffen dass
diese sowohl sich selbst als ungeimpften
schützen Friedemann gehst du gerne in
Club wo auch 3G gestattet ist mit einem
deutlich schlechteren Gefühl als Zweige
und ich finde das ist eines der vielen
Dilemmata dieser Pandemie dass man sehr
genau und kleinteilig abwägen muss ich
bin auch in kleinen Schritt vorgegangen
als Lutz über Inklusion gesprochen hat
ich bin habe ein großes Herz für die
Clubkultur ich gehe selber gerne feiern
aber im Zweifelsfall finde ich muss an
der Stelle Inklusion zurückstehen und
Solidarität nach vorne gestellt werden
und ich finde das Signal was man damit
im Endeffekt sendet ist das Impfen so
was ist wie eine Lifestyle Entscheidung
ja was für Schuhe ich mir anziehe oder
ob ich eine dicke Jacke oder eine dünne
Jacke anziehe und da hätte ich mir auf
jeden Fall eine andere Aussage gewünscht
wer sich in dieser Situation nicht
impfen lassen will der darf auch nicht
darauf hoffen dass wir alle Rücksicht
mit den rücksichtslosen haben
Gesellschaft funktioniert nur mit
Solidarität und eine Impfung in einer
Pandemie die so sicher und weit
verbreitet ist ist genau dieses bisschen
Solidarität was jeder und jede geben
müsste jetzt ist mir Miriam und habe ich
nachher sind getrieben es tut mir leid
nach hinten getrieben aber wir werden
vielleicht kriegen wir sie auch wieder
nach vorne Miriam du bist glaube ich
nicht geimpft das heißt du könntest
jetzt sagen du darfst jetzt nicht in
Substanzen gehen und du darfst auch
nicht in seine Bar trinken gehen fühlst
du dich diskriminiert also 100 Prozent
und entschuldigung ich bin gerade der
Satz impfen ist eine Lifestyle
Entscheidung
nein ich sagte das Signal was man dann
und aussendet ist impfen ist so eine
Entscheidung wo jeder so ein bisschen
nach Bauchgefühl gehen kann und das
finde ich falsch ich finde es auch
falsch nach Bauchgefühl zu gehen ich bin
sehr dafür nach Zahlen und Fakten zu
gehen deswegen muss ich noch mal kurz
eins zurückgehen was du gesagt hast Elke
danke auch eine Impfung schützt nicht
das Umfeld das ist ja das was jetzt auf
dem Tisch liegt und ganz klar ist stimmt
nicht kurz Ausreden eine Impfung schützt
vor allem einen selbst vor einem
möglichen schweren Verlauf und ich finde
deswegen ist es keine Bauchentscheidung
sondern ich persönlich zum Beispiel habe
einfach geguckt ich habe mir die Zahlen
angeguckt wie sieht's aus ich bin jung
ich bin gesund ich bin fit ich bin
schlank wie groß ist meine Chance dass
ich einen schweren Verlauf habe im
Vergleich zu wie groß ist meine Chance
dass diese Impfung mir vielleicht nicht
gut tut und da bin ich zu dem Entschluss
gekommen mich nicht impfen zu lassen und
diese Entscheidung muss man jedem
Menschen über seinen eigenen Körper
lassen darf ich kurz bitte trifft
eigentlich genau den Punkt Lutz war
richtig ne er meinte ist es eine
individuelle Entscheidung zu sagen ich
nehme das Risiko auf mich jetzt in den
Club zu gehen der jetzt 3G hat aber wir
wissen doch jetzt in einem Rahmen der
Pandemie das ist eben keine individuelle
Entscheidung ist weil ich ja dieses
Virus auch unbemerkt einfach weitergeben
kann oder also mich nicht nur selber
infizieren kann ob im Rahmen des
eigenschutzes kann ich ja sagen okay das
Risiko nehme ich auf mich aber in dem
Augenblick wo ich dann meine Familie
reintrage oder ein Kinder oder Leute die
sich nicht impfen können bis zum
heutigen Zeitpunkt darum geht es ja auch
die mit zu schützen finde ich das
schwierig also ich bin also ich bin kein
Mediziner aber ich glaube den Punkt
haben wir längst überschritten jetzt hat
jeder einen impfangebot jeder der
geimpft ist hat auch so wie du schon
gesagt hast das Risiko vermindert dass
man schweren Verlauf hat und wie lange
wollen wir eigentlich diesen Prozess
dann noch aufrechterhalten also bis der
letzte Mahner befriedigt ist wir sind
jetzt bei einer hohen gimpft wurde wir
sehen auch in anderen Ländern dass sie
so hoch pro Impfquote auch dafür
zugeführt hat dass sie zahlen
runtergehen dass die die
Krankenhausbetten nicht mehr belegt sind
oder geringer belegt sind und ich meine
das am Ende der Mensch selbst
entscheiden muss und es auch eine
bessere persönliche Entscheidung ob ich
mich impfen lasse oder nicht ich bin ge
ich habe auch diese Entscheidung selbst
getroffen ich meine aber dass ich das
nicht jemand anders abnehmen kann also
mal ganz kurz um das klarzustellen wir
reden einmal um die über die Frage ist
das eine rein persönliche Entscheidung
oder ist es so wie Erik sagt eben nicht
nur eine persönliche sondern auch eine
darüber hinausgehen solidarische
Entscheidung um andere Leute zu schützen
ich fasse nur kurz zusammen danach dürft
ihr gleich wie Miriam sagt moment mal
Impfung hilft vor allem mir selbst das
hilft den anderen wenig bis gar nicht
habe ich dich richtig verstanden
nachdem was ich lese beim RKI hilft es
zumindest der Verbreitung sondern die
Wahrscheinlichkeit der Verbreiterung ist
geringer durch viele geimpfte Menschen
das sagt das RKI aktuell zumindest auf
der Webseite ihr sagt ja argumentiert
dagegen ihr sagt das ist eben nicht nur
eine persönliche Entscheidung für das
Maus im Einsatz zu nutzen noch ganz gut
ich glaube das ist eines der großen
Missverständnisse auch der Pandemie
Spalten tun nicht die Regeln Spalten tun
Menschen die sich gegen die Solidarität
entscheiden und in einer Pandemie ich
glaube das haben wir alle irgendwann mal
inzwischen verstanden wie auch in vielen
anderen Teil das gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenlebens gibt es diese
Entscheidung nur für mich nicht wenn ich
in einer Gesellschaft lebe dann muss ich
auch ein bisschen schauen was meine
Entscheidung mit den anderen machen und
das kam zum Beispiel in deiner
Begründung in keinster Weise vor guck
dir an andere Länder Israel Israel
Island zum Beispiel die haben wahnsinnig
hohe Impfquoten die Inzidenzen sind
total hoch es ist einfach nicht so wir
haben jetzt ich habe gestern glaube ich
noch mal vorbereitet habe Herrn
Professor Doktor dr Drosten noch mal
angehört diese ganzen langen Podcasts
mir angehört da wird die Rede Professor
Dr Drosten sagt das sind zwei Monate
zwei Monate hat man diesen vollständigen
Impfschutz entschuldige da kann ich
keinen solchen Unterschied zwischen
geimpften und ungeimpften ziehen wenn
der Impfschutz so schlecht ist das will
keine aussprechen weil das ist ja die
einzige Strategie die die Regierung
gerade vorgibt ist impfen impfen impfen
aber wie gut die Impfung funktioniert
wenn wir um Solidarität reden die
funktioniert dann nicht gut die macht
einen guten Selbstschutz mehr nicht
jetzt müssen wir ganz kurz medizinisch
werden also ich fasse noch mal ganz kurz
zusammen gibt verschiedene warten ich
glaube wir können uns aber darauf
einigen die Wahrscheinlichkeit der
Ausbreitung des Virus wird gemindert
wenn möglichst viele Menschen geimpft
sind sind wir uns da einig dass wir uns
einig ja und wir bedingt also nein
bedingt dahingehend wenn wir auf sind
wir auf individueller Ebene oder auf
bevölkerungsebene und das ist das miriam
hat sie gerade angesprochen dass es vor
allem ein individualschutz ist also die
Idee die man mal hatte und die wunderbar
wäre hätte sie funktioniert dass man
eine herdenimmunität erreichen kann die
der hängen wir noch nach und politische
Entscheidungen werden aktuell immer noch
von dieser Illusion getragen dass das so
sei aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit der
Weitergabe sinkt mit einer Impfung auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich gesehen das
würdest du doch trotzdem zustimmen auch
wenn es kein hundertprozent-schutz ist
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit sinkt oder
nicht das wäre jetzt natürlich schwierig
wenn wir da keinen Grund also diesen
Konsens bräuchten wir sonst können wir
gar nicht weiter diskutieren aber das
ist ja die Grundlage von allem das ist
ja das warum die Fronten so verhärtet
sind
also der ist reduziert aber die Frage
ist in welchem Maße natürlich ist das
reduziert in welchem Maße ist unklar
darf ich da was dazu sagen weil da gibt
es Daten dazu lassen wir es auch mal
Ecke hören also so ein paar da diesen
Fakten die Impfung schützt die ersten
zwei Monate gleichmäßig vor der
Erkrankung und vor der Weitergabe der
Erkrankung nach zwei Monaten beginnt es
dass diese dieser Impfschutz langsam
weniger wird da ist nach sechs Monaten
immer noch gut vorhanden wenn derjenige
der geimpft ist keine immuneffizienz hat
da gibt es auch kein Essenz so und jetzt
das heißt aber nicht dass nach zwei
Monaten die Impfung nichts mehr bringt
das heißt auch nicht dass die nach zwei
Monaten die Impfung nicht mehr vor
Weitergabe schützt die Weitergabe der
weitergabeschutz der Impfung ist laut
dem Dossier vom RKI dass die Impfungen
von Beginn der Impfserie 27.12 bis zum
31.08 ausgewertet hat dass das ist
september erschienen reduziert dieser
Impfschutz zumindest bei kombinati also
bei den mrna-impfstoffen die Viruslast
im Körper die weitergegeben werden kann
auf
25%. das heißt ich dafür wenn ich
geimpft bin 25 nur noch 25 Prozent so
ansteckend wie jemand der ungeimpft ist
und der zur gleichen Zeit infiziert
wurde so und dann dann deine Antwort auf
Lutz Lutz sagt stimmt dir zu er sagt ich
glaube dir ja aber ich finde wir sollten
jetzt die Regeln trotzdem so öffnen dass
man sagt ihr könnt euch alle impfen wenn
ihr wollt und dann könnt ihr auch wieder
feiern gehen was sagst du ihm ihr könnt
euch alle impfen wenn ihr wollt und
könnt dann auch feiern gehen das wäre
meiner Antwort dazu weil derjenige der
ungeimpft ist und ich bin im Augenblick
sehr unsicher ob ich nicht lieber meine
Maske anziehe da ungeimpft im Raum sind
und ich diene zusätzlich gefährdet bin
natürlich
hier nein ich möchte jemand ungeimpftes
nicht gefährden deswegen verlange ich
von dass du die Maske aufziehst aber ich
würde aus meinem persönlichen Empfinden
aber das ist doch genau das was auch
Entschuldigung ein Herr Lauterbach das
Gefühl hat er müsste alle Menschen vor
allem schützen nein handelt individuell
entscheiden ich war auch in Zeiten am
Wochenende hierher gefahren ich war
teilweise nicht angeschnallt ich möchte
nicht dich schützen sondern ich möchte
denjenigen Schützen der deinen
intensivplatz bekommen könnte und eine
Krebsoperation bekommen könnte den
möchte ich dann kann ich auch nicht mehr
reiten nicht mehr Skifahren
dass wir alle
jemand von euch schon mal auf einer
Intensivstation mit egmo weil jemand von
euch schon mal auch bei Intensivstation
ist bestimmt entscheidet dass er zum
Beispiel mit 150 Sachen ein Berg runter
fährt mit seinen Skiern dann ist seine
persönliche Entscheidung und wer da im
Krankenhaus landet kann ich es auch
nicht unterbinden das heißt welche was
maßen wir uns an dass wir den Menschen
zunehmend vorschreiben was sie zu machen
haben was sie nicht zu machen haben wenn
sie es eigene Risiko ich zähle das
Argument mit den mit den Betten dass die
irgendwann belegt sind und dann muss man
wahrscheinlich auch die Maßnahmen wieder
verschärfen aber da sind wir weiter von
entfernt wenn die Betten belegt sind und
die Maßnahmen zu verschärfen sind immer
etwa drei bis vier Wochen zu spät ich
glaube wir vermischen sterben nach wie
vor ein Herz-Kreislauf-Krankheiten
wollen wir jetzt allen Leuten
vorschreiben dass sie dreimal die Woche
Sport machen sich vegan ernähren also im
Prinzip das Thema war ja schon vor
Corona da ist die Intensivstationen viel
zu tun haben ich glaube dass wir einfach
zu wenig oder dass die Bevölkerung zu
wenig von dem Leid mitbekommen hat das
kovic selber das glaube ich nicht also
ich glaube nicht jeder Zeitungs ich
würde mal gerne gerne von dir wissen
Eric wie verfolgst du gerade dieses
Diskussion also ich verfolge die
Situation gerade so dass ich nicht ganz
verstehen kann das Argument von Lutz
weil ich habe er sagt zwar auf der einen
Seite jeder hat jetzt das Angebot gehabt
wie lange wollen wir noch die Maßnahmen
ertragen sie sind natürlich komplett
unpopulär bin ich auch bei dir aber ist
nur unprobleme Maßnahme die uns davor
schützt dass in einer Situation zu
geraten wir sind noch nach wie vor in
der Pandemie wir haben zwar den Satz
jeder hat ein ange aber wir haben leider
zu viele die gesagt haben nee ich nehme
dieses Angebot nicht an aber das ist
auch nicht richtig also wenn wir jetzt
mal kurz Ausreden mein Problem als ich
habe ist wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel als
Club oder in meinem Fall als Bar also
ich würde jetzt auch zum Beispiel nicht
sagen ich mache jetzt 3G als
Familienrestaurant oder als Supermarkt
bin ich auch dagegen aber ich habe eine
Nachbar die bis 5 6 Uhr morgens offen
hat und ich bin ein Ort der Ansteckung
so und wenn ich jetzt zugestehen würde
dass ich sage okay es können auch
ungeimpfte einfach reinkommen nee der
Test hat ja noch ein nächstes Problem
ich kann ja negativ getestet sein und
plötzlich aber und schon trotzdem längst
hochinfektiös weil er erst nach drei
oder vier Tagen anschlägt also ich habe
immer noch diese Latenz dazwischen ich
möchte nicht dass ich das Problem indem
wir uns befinden gesamtgesellschaftlich
und das da möchte ich einfach raus ich
möchte über Corona nicht mehr reden aber
ich will das nicht finden ich verlängern
und wenn ich als Bar sage ich mache 3G
dann verlängere ich dieses Problem neben
uns gerade befinden um noch vielleicht
ein Vierteljahr und das möchte ich
einfach nicht möchte dass es
verschwindet so und genau darum geht es
um Maßnahmen die geimpfte und ungeimpfte
unterschiedlich treffen jetzt kommt
ganz viel durcheinander sehe ich gerade
also es ist nicht das Virus das dazu
führt dass wir diese Beschränkung haben
sondern es sind politische
Entscheidungen mein Statement dazu ist
ganz klar entweder es gibt eine
testpflicht für alle ja eben vor diesem
Hintergrund dass auch geimpfte nach wie
vor zum Infektionsgeschehen und zwar
nicht unerheblich beitragen oder man
hebt eben auch die Zugangsbeschränkungen
für alle auf aber diese
Ungleichbehandlung die ist am Ende des
Tages willkürlich und daher
schnellstmöglich zu beenden wir sehen
dass wir mit andere Länder schaut
Schweden zum Beispiel von Anfang an ganz
andere Weg gegangen Dänemark Niederlande
Großbritannien haben geöffnet das sind
die Inzidenzen höher das sind auch die
Krankenhauseinlieferungen zumindest für
das ist aber eine politische
Entscheidung so zu tun als ob es quasi
Naturgesetz wäre wenn dann als wäre es
die Schwerkraft das ist im Diskurs wird
es so behandelt als kann das nur so sein
das ist das ist falsch es ist eine
politische Entscheidung die genauso
anders lauten könnte die können genauso
heiß wir heben jetzt alle Maßnahmen auf
jeder hat eben für Angebot bekommen ab
12 Jahre kann es annehmen kann es lassen
eine systemische Überlastung droht nicht
mehr lasst uns mal bitte versuchen an
einem Punkt zu bleiben wir haben jetzt
angefangen mit 2g-regelungen und
3g-regelungen damit sind wir
eingestiegen und ich weiß du hast schon
gegen viele Maßnahmen auch geklagt mit
mehr oder weniger großen Erfolg da ging
es um die sinnlosen Maßnahmen wie 1,5
km-regelung es ging um Ausgangssperren
und jetzt geht es unter anderem auch um
die 2g-frage ich weiß bei 2G kommst du
aus dem Kopfstand nicht mehr raus sag
doch mal ganz kurz aus rechtlicher Sicht
warum
auf dem Punkt gebracht Infektionsschutz
ist Gefahrenabwehr das heißt ich muss
schauen wer potenziell gefährdet und
wobei wir uns da offensichtlich nicht
ganz einig werden hier
aus meiner Sicht wie ich das ganze
beurteile ist es eben so dass geimpfte
ebenso relevant zum Infektionsgeschehen
von mir aus vermindert aber immer noch
relevant beitragen und alleine deswegen
ist es nicht gerechtfertigt quasi
geimpfte zu privilegieren und zu sagen
wir behandeln Sie so als würden sie
niemanden gefährden oder so gut wie
niemanden gefährden das ist nämlich
einfach nicht der Fakt Friedemann kannst
du das Nachvollziehen also ich gehe sehr
sehr gerne einen Schritt nach vorne
einerseits weil ich mich selber
gewundert habe wie konfrontativ es wird
das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht und
zweitens weil ich immer gerne auf
Expertin höre und du bist Juristin und
ich dachte mir schon dass du sehr sehr
gute Argumente auch hast für deinen
Standpunkt ich würde aber vielleicht
noch mal versuchen eins größer drauf zu
schauen wir leben nun mal in der
liberalen Demokratie in der Gesellschaft
die ist enorm darauf angewiesen dass wir
solidarisch sind und dass wir gewisse
Regeln der Solidarität aus auch
aushandeln demokratisch transparent in
einem Parlament und sie in Gesetze
gießen das ist nie perfekt und ich gebe
euch absolut recht das ist sehr gute
Argumente auch gegen eine zweijährigen
umgibt und ich würde auch noch mal
betonen dass ich der erste wäre der
gegen eine Impfpflicht auf die Straße
geht weil das ist mit anderen Werten
nicht zu vereinbaren wir müssen aber und
gerade in der Situation die für uns alle
neu ist wie einer globalen Pandemie
manchmal Absprachen treffen und
Regelungen treffen die nicht perfekt
sind und gegen dieses Argumente gibt so
wie wir wenn wir einfach Vergleich am
Straßenverkehr teilnehmen wollen gewisse
Regeln beachten müssen die sind
vielleicht nicht für alle sofort
einleuchtend aber sie haben sich so ganz
gut erwiesen wir haben nur leider keine
Zeit über Jahre und Jahrzehnte
herauszufinden ob eine Gurtpflicht gut
ist oder nicht die glaube ich in
Deutschland erst 1969 gegen großen
Widerstand eingeführt wurde und die
glaube ich heute uns allen sinnvoll
erscheint und ich finde im Zweifelsfall
muss man die ein oder andere Kröte
schlucken solange es zum Beispiel nicht
an die Unversehrtheit des Körpers geht
um das was wir ja alle schätzen und was
wir alle enorm vermisst haben nämlich
gesellschaftliches Zusammenleben wieder
möglichst sicher nicht 100% sicher
gibt's nicht möglichst sicher wieder
einführen zu können du hast es geschafft
manche sind nach vorne gegangen und
Miriam hat eine Antwort
ich habe auch gar keine Lust zu streiten
mit euch
du hast mehrere Dinge gesagt
parlamentarisch da bin ich auch dafür
wir haben aber nach wie vor diese
epidemische Notlage die dazu führt dass
es eben nicht mehr komplett im Parlament
alles besprochen wird sondern ein Herr
Spahn Beschlüsse machen kann und ich bin
sehr dafür dass es demokratischer wird
und das Meer diskutiert wird weil das
passiert gerade zu wenig und wenn du
sagst diese das ist dieses blöde
Beispiel was mir auch immer den Kopf
geworfen wird mit der Anschnallpflicht
ich schnalle mich auch an ich bin auch
dafür dass man sich anschnallt aber ich
würde jetzt nicht an der roten Ampel
aussteigen wenn ich sehe der da ist
nicht angeschnallt klopfen und sagen
sagen Sie mal schneiden Sie sich bitte
an weil ich habe irgendwie Angst dass
sie sonst auf der Intensivstation landen
und mir dann einen Platz eventuell
wegnehmen oder jemandem anderen und das
passiert aber gerade mit den ungeimpften
finde ich und ich glaube dass man dieses
anklopfen macht und sich woran ist man
dieses Recht entschuldige und die
körperliche unversehrte solange es nicht
an die körperliche Unversehrtheit geht
genau da bin ich auch dafür aber
tatsächlich wissen wir nicht ob diese
Impfung nicht doch an körperliche
Unversehrtheit geht darf ich einen Satz
dazu sagen ich finde es schön wie Du
darauf eingegangen bist ich finde wenn
man sich in der Situation gegen die
Impfung entscheidet und das rechts
sollte man haben muss man mit dem
anklopfen an die Scheibe im Zweifelsfall
leben also ich würde dagegen
argumentieren und sagen es geht um
Verhältnismäßigkeit und bis zu von paar
Monaten war ich total Unterstützer und
bin nach wie vor genau das sollen sich
impfen lassen wir haben sogar impfnechte
veranstaltet in Berlin wir haben
wirklich campaigns dafür gemacht weil
wir eben auch glauben so wie du auch wir
müssen wieder zu einer Normalität
zurückkommen und impfen ist dafür
wichtig es geht aber jetzt quasi jetzt
sind wir an den Punkt gekommen wo ich
glaube jetzt müssen wir über die
Verhältnismäßigkeit sprechen und auch
wieder selbstbestimmt Leute entscheiden
lassen und ich glaube nicht dass wir die
Entscheidung den Menschen abnehmen
können und ich fange auch nicht an jetzt
über Prozente diskutieren ob das jetzt
bei 82 83 85% möglich ist weil das bin
ich auch eher bei euch dass die Gefahr
dass wir doch nicht zu einer
herdenimmunität kommen einfach zu groß
ist und dann müssen wir anders mit der
Pandemie umgehen aber für du hast ja
irgendwann krit dann habe das immer sagt
wir haben 10 bis 15 Prozent umgeimpfte
mögliche Clubgäste das ist für euch dann
die Grenze gewesen die Clubs sind wieder
offen unter zwei geregelung und wir
lassen aber eben einen großen Teil
unserer Community außen vor und als
Gesellschaft ist unsere bei unserer
Aufgabe wir sehen das sozusagen als
Clubs Menschen zusammenzubringen und
eben auch in dieser pandemiezeit und
postpandemiezeit wieder die Gesellschaft
zusammenzuführen und das geht eben nicht
wenn wir ihnen die Pistole auf die Brust
setzen und sagen es geht nur wenn ihr
geimpft seid dann sage ich lieber lasst
euch testen dass jemand anders gefährdet
aber ihr könnt selbst persönliches
Risiko eingehen dass eure persönliche
Entscheidung und die kann ich euch auch
nicht abnehmen also für ihn ist die
Grenze einfach erreicht der Punkt an dem
er sagt okay jetzt jetzt sind wir schon
soweit es gibt so wenige ungeimpfte
zumindest bei dir und bei dir zumindest
da wo wir alle wollen für dich wäre die
Grenze jetzt erreicht wo du sagst okay
wir können jetzt diese Maßnahmen vor
allem diese Unterscheidung zwischen
geimpft und ungeimpft können wert sein
lassen wo ist denn für euch der Punkt
also ab wann sagt man jetzt treffen wir
keine Unterscheidung mehr jetzt machen
wir Dänemark Modell alles auf na wenn
wir die Impfquoten haben wir dort also
zum Beispiel Prozent man darf ja bei
Dänemark und Portugal und diesen ganzen
Vergleichsländern nicht vergessen dass
die zu einer Zeit geöffnet haben oder
Schutz speziell England das war im
Sommer oder im also weit Monate zurück
jetzt und wenn wir jetzt das im Herbst
machen wo die Inzidenzen aufgrund der
Saisonalität sowieso steigen werden dann
ist es vielleicht ja völlig falsche
Zeitpunkt also ich bin ja komplett bei
dir diese Grenze ich möchte Sie auch
unbedingt überschreiten ich möchte
niemanden vor der Bar abweisen müssen
möchte sagen du bist ungeimpft du bist
nicht geimpft du ja du nein das möchte
ich nicht ganz im Gegenteil aber ich bin
gezwungenes zu machen weil wenn ich
jetzt sage als Club z.B als Bar ich
mache jetzt hier 3G ich möchte ich
akzeptiere diesen Test der hier mir
nachts um zwei von fünf besoffenen Typen
vor die Nase gehalten wird dann weiß ich
ganz genau das ist gefaked es ist nicht
richtig es ist falsch also wir wissen
das ist deine was ist deine Sorge was
was glaubst du du hast Angst vor der
Überlastung der intensiv Situation ja
die Sorge ist nicht das was bei mir
individuell ist sondern wenn wir
insgesamt gesellschaftlich sagen okay
auch nachts im Clubs jetzt in Berlin
oder München oder in Köln können jetzt
3G Modus gefahren werden dann haben wir
das Problem dass wenn sich jemand im
Test dort anmelden sagt er ist negativ
er trotzdem längst hochgradig infektiös
sein kann so und wenn er dann sich in
diesem Kontext bewegt wir hatten Ischgl
vor Augen wir wissen doch mittlerweile
was mit dem Virus passiert und wie es
sich verbreitet so und dann ist genau
der Kontext in dem wir uns befinden dann
der Faktor der dafür sorgt dass wir die
ganze Inzidenz wieder nach oben schießen
und deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung
das ist asoziales zu sagen ich mache
hier 3G weil die Gesellschaft hat mich
ja auch bei die 8 Monate Schließzeit
hinweg getragen die haben mehr Gelder
bezahlt wenn ich jetzt künstlich ganzen
beitragen
dann ist das kontraproduktiv aber
Jessica kannst du das nachvollziehen
dass er sagt Moment er erwartet auch die
Grenze er will gerne den Punkt erreichen
wo man das alles einfach wo man
Maßnahmen abschaffen kann aber für ihn
ist aus verschiedenen Gründen dieser
Punkt noch nicht erreicht bis dahin
brauchen wir diese Unterscheidung
zwischen geimpft und ungeimpft kannst du
das nachvollziehen die Idee die
wirtschaftliche Not ich glaube aber auch
dass es der dass es ein schlechtes
Zeichen ist an diejenigen du hast auch
gesagt das muss eine freie Entscheidung
sein auch du hast gesagt muss eine freie
Entscheidung sein hast gesagt man muss
das parlamentarisch bestimmen muss man
was wir jetzt aber erleben ist eine
faktische Impfpflicht ich kann jetzt
habe jetzt die Wahl mich ausschließen zu
lassen aus der Gesellschaft oder ich
habe die Wahl mich impfen zu lassen das
ist keine richtige das ist keine
richtige Wahl letzten Endes das heißt
die ehrliche Variante wäre dafür würde
ich auch plädieren wenn man meint man
muss das machen dann soll man es ehrlich
machen und dann macht man eine
Impfpflicht und dann werden wir die
rechtlich überprüfen lassen so können
wir das nicht und auch ganz kurz ich
dachte du sagst gleich die Impfpflicht
durch die Hintertür du hast jetzt gesagt
faktische Impfpflicht ich finde ich
glaube uns verbindet eins professionell
wir arbeiten mit Sprache und ich glaube
du wirst dir genau überlegt haben warum
du es so nennst ich würde widersprechen
eine Impfpflicht ist eine Impfpflicht
und ein unterschiedlicher Zugang ganz
bestimmten Bereichen der sich ja auch
nicht auf die gesamte Gesellschaft
scheidet du darfst ja auch noch aus dem
Haus gehen niemand verbietet dir noch
noch rauszugehen ja aber das muss man
einmal festhalten ja man kann ja auch
nicht so tun als sehr gerne man kann ja
auch nichts zu tun als wären die
ungeimpften jetzt im Gefängnis sondern
es gibt bestimmte Räume
gesellschaftliche Räume ja wo wir uns
gegenseitig schützen wollen wo wir uns
begegnen wollen zum Beispiel die Clubs
und da kann man unterschiedlich
entscheiden welches Risiko wir eingehen
deswegen finde ich es ganz wichtig
nochmal festzuhalten es ist auch keine
Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür Miriam
du fühlst dich wie im Gefängnis ich
fühle mich nicht im Gefängnis weil ich
lebe aus dem Land und da kann ich
sowieso machen was ich möchte aber es
geht darum dass es auch Berufe betrifft
ich kenne Kindergartenpädagoginnen die
ihren Job gekündigt haben oder worden
sind ich kenne Krankenschwestern die
ihren Job haben fallen lassen schlecht
in der Pandemie
Krankenhauspersonal kündigt ich kenne
auch Schauspieler und Schauspielerinnen
die gerade nicht arbeiten können weil
sie ungeimpft sind das ich glaube als
geimpfter ist es leicht zu sagen ja es
geht ja nur um den Club oder um sowas es
geht wirklich um viel mehr
und das kann man nicht ignorieren oder
wegläuten weil das passiert einfach
gerade also aus meiner Beratungspraxis
kann ich dir sagen das betrifft eben
nicht nur das Freizeit fahren das
betrifft die Arbeit zum Beispiel gibt es
ein Geschäftsessen dann ist sie okay was
mache ich jetzt es ist 2G wie komme ich
jetzt ich will auch nicht ich will mich
auch nicht outen weil ich habe Angst
meine Karriere zu gefährden solche Fälle
gibt sie sind real und die passieren
jetzt nicht nur ein oder zweimal diesen
real Hochschulen Zugang über 3G in
meinem Bundesland müssen die Tests
selbst bezahlt werden keine
selbsttestmöglich das ist nicht leistbar
ja letzten Endes also zu sagen naja man
kann doch und es ist doch eigentlich
auch gar keine richtige richtige
pflichter macht man sich zu einfach das
ist immer ganz kurz bei dem Punkt bei
Miri mit der aufgeworfen es geht eben
nicht nur darum ob ich mal in den Club
gehen kann und feiern bei manchen
Menschen geht es um die Existenz es geht
um es geht darum dass ich meinen Beruf
vielleicht nicht mehr ausüben kann weil
ich mich dafür entschieden habe mich
nicht impfen zu lassen aus welchen
Gründen auch immer vielleicht sind es
sogar die komplett falschen Gründe kann
ja sein ist es dann trotzdem gerecht den
Leuten zu sagen sorry da darf es halt
nicht mehr arbeiten es wird der Punkt da
können die wieder arbeiten aber genau in
der jetzigen Situation der Pandemie eben
nicht darüber reden wir doch wie das
heißt worüber gehen nimmst du das in
Kauf als als Kröte die man schlucken
also ich würde mich jetzt nicht in die
Situation setzen sagen du darfst den Job
jetzt nicht mehr machen das ist das
möchte ich mir jetzt nicht anmaßen aber
ich möchte jetzt auch
als Arbeitgeber überhaupt nicht fragen
ob derjenige geimpft ist oder nicht
natürlich nicht aber es passiert ja
praktisch trotzdem und ich bin die Frage
darf derjenige der ungeimpft sind ist
Lügen genau
Konsequenzen hast du Recht aber das
Problem ist dann wenn wirklich sowas wie
ein es gibt viele Veranstaltungen auch
also auf 2G Veranstaltungen gehen quasi
und dann müssen sie sich outen lassen
wie machen dass die Leute sind dann
krank oder ähnliches also das sind die
Dinge die die mir gesagt werden weil in
dem Moment muss ich mich ja outen oder
ich habe ein Arbeitsessen mit dem Chef
dann muss ich auch Nachweis haben ja
also das ist das Problem dass man das
nur bedingt tatsächlich geheim halten
kann auch wenn es rechtlich ich finde
vorschlagen ich soll Lügen ich möchte
doch gar nicht lügen müssen
zwei g-regelungen ist auf jeden Fall
eine Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür und
das ist auch okay so ich finde man soll
den Druck erhöhen dass ich möglichst
viele Menschen impfen lassen damit ich
total bei euch aber das kann man auch
nur gewissen Zeitraum machen man muss
sich angucken wie die Impfbereitschaft
ist und wenn die irgendwann Stocken
gerät oder gar nicht mehr da ist dann
muss man den Menschen auch ihre
Entscheidung dann auch überlassen und
dann soll man es ihnen immer noch nicht
so einfach machen von mir aus kann man
auch für ein Test bezahlen wenn man dann
im Schnelltest oder ein PCR-Test macht
und möglichst günstig das auch die
Teilhabe wieder möglich ist und sich
jede leisten kann aber wir sind an dem
Punkt wo wir sagen müssen Leute wir
können nicht Leute einfach außen vor
lassen und wenn Sie sich einfach nicht
impfen lassen wollen und ein Risiko ein
persönlich Risiko eingehen möchten dann
müssen Sie auch das machen
überzeugt du bist gleich dran Du bist
auch gleich ein Stück weit weil ich den
Punkt der Teilhabe und gerade bei sozial
schwachen Menschen total völlig verstehe
ich glaube da sind wir relativ nah
beieinander und ich würde auch noch mal
wer noch mal dran interessiert zu
diskutieren wie bekommt man die die sich
noch nicht geimpft haben vielleicht
erreichbar wären ja oder welchen Gründen
auch immer weil sie vielleicht nicht so
gut Deutsch sprechen weil sie den nicht
den Zugang zu Informationen haben weil
sie vielleicht auch einfach den Ernst
der Lage in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren noch nicht so verstanden haben
und wenn man es anders kommunizieren
würde würde man sie kriegen ich finde
darüber reden wir immer noch zu wenig
und da muss natürlich noch sehr viel
passieren wir reden aber auch sehr wenig
über Leute die in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren große Lasten getragen haben Leute
die eben sehr gefährdet waren die
immunerkrankungen haben die sogenannten
Armen und Schwachen die wir schützen
müssen und Leute die sich vielleicht am
impfen lassen auch vielleicht mit einem
bisschen Bauchweh ich bekomme auch nicht
gerne eine Spritze in den Armen von der
ich natürlich nie tausend Prozent weiß
was sie ausmacht so jetzt bin ich ein
Kind von Pharmazeuten das heißt ich
meine Eltern ganz gut darüber
diskutieren was bedeutet zum Beispiel
ein beschleunigt ist zusatzungsverfahren
die haben mich dahingehend auch
beruhigen können und trotzdem glaube ich
gibt es in dem Land Millionen Leute die
sich nicht am impfen lassen weil sie
Bock auf eine Spritze haben oder weil
sie 100% davon überzeugt sind sondern
auch aus Solidarität und über die Reden
nicht ganz ganz kurz das heißt du bist
sofort dran das heißt Du bleibst dabei
impfen ist ein Akt der Solidarität ja
also und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt Miriam
direkt darauf weil ich glaube auch dass
sich sehr viele Menschen haben impfen
lassen aber für mich nicht als
Solidarität sondern um wieder normal
leben zu können um zurückzukommen zu dem
Leben wie es vor Corona war so wie du
das vorher von mir dass man will doch
einfach dass es vorbei ist ja aber mein
Punkt ist ich glaube nicht dass das die
Impfung dazu braucht das ist eine
politische Entscheidung diese Pandemie
zu beenden oder nicht zu beenden was
meint ihr eigentlich ist das ganze
überhaupt eine Frage der Solidarität und
wenn nicht welche Frage ist es denn dann
schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare und
jetzt kommt Jessica dran wenn ich da nur
ergänzen darf die aus diesem Prinzip so
dargestellt als und das ist auch das was
in der Öffentlichkeit so kolportiert
wird als seine Entscheidung gegen die
Impfung entweder ist also irgendwas
stimmt mit dem Menschen nicht der ist
entweder dumm oder versteht keinen also
versteht vielleicht kein Deutsch oder
ist unsolidarisch aber dass das finde
ich schwierig weil ich persönlich meine
Haltung ist jeder darf selbst
entscheiden Risikoabwägung Kosten Nutzen
Abwägung machen ob er sich impfen lässt
oder nicht und das habe ich nicht zu
bewerten ich persönlich ehrlich gesagt
interessiert es mich auch nicht so
wahnsinnig brennend warum sich jemand
dafür oder dagegen entscheide so
deswegen würde ich mir das nicht anmaßen
und stimme dir im ersten Teil total zu
der zweite Teil finde ich interessant
weil der glaube ich oft in der Pandemie
jetzt auch falsch verstanden wurde auch
in anderen politischen Diskussionen
natürlich maßen wir uns als Gesellschaft
an ganz ganz vielen Stellen an Verhalten
in Anführungsstrichen zu bewerten indem
wir es zum Beispiel unter Strafe stellen
oder indem wir gewisse Regeln
aufrechterhalten und um beim Beispiel
verkehrt zu bleiben wenn ich da
rausgehen
werfe ich mich einem komplizierten und
sehr sehr dicken Set an Regeln damit ich
am Verkehr teilnehmen kann um was zu
ermöglichen halbwegs sicherer
friedlicher Verkehr und Mobilität weil
es ein hohes Gut ist das heißt der
letzte Satz da muss ich widersprechen
wir bewerten und wir stufen ein die
ganze Zeit und das bedeutet
zusammenlegen und die die gibt's nicht
und das sage ich habe gesagt ich kann
manchmal eine Impfpflicht also ich bin
dafür dass man mit offenen Karten spielt
und dann gibt es eben eine Pflicht und
dann kann ich dagegen vorgehen jetzt
gibt es die nicht und es ist gibt diesen
sozialen Druck wir haben uns
eingeschränkt wir haben uns den Peaks
geben lassen damit alle die ganze
Gesellschaft da wieder rauskommt ihr
wollt das nicht machen und das empfinden
manche als unsolidarisch erkennst du an
das ist auch für dich hilfreich sein
kann dass die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
sich hat impfen lassen
nein ich habe tatsächlich also ja
ich persönlich medizinisch ist der ist
ist die die Gefahr dass eben viele
Menschen ins Krankenhaus kommt deutlich
geringer wenn die Leute geimpft sind das
ist
okay gut da bin ich auch einig aber ich
habe niemanden ich persönlich Miriam
habe niemanden darum gebeten sich für
mich impfen zu lassen weil ich wie
gesagt denke ich würde dieses Virus
überleben und wenn nicht dann habe ich
mich geirrt dann war das meine
Entscheidung der Friede Mann wollte
darauf warten
von meiner Impfung gegen das ist mir
einfach persönlich was meine Mischung
aus Gründen tatsächlich das war aber
auch der solidarische Gedanke und ich
hätte einfach nicht damit leben können
ob es dann passiert oder nicht aber dass
ich auch ein wandelndes Risiko bin
einerseits selber schwer zu erkranken
weil es erkranken leider auch gesunde
mittelalte Männer und zweitens jemand
anderen vielleicht anzustecken weil das
durchaus auch immer wieder vorkommt und
ich hätte auch einer Krankenschwester
oder einer Ärztin ins Gesicht schauen
können und sagen können naja aber das
Risiko habe ich bin ich eben eingegeben
grundrichter auf wo die Angst der
anderen anfängt und da müssen wir wieder
hinkommen und wir müssen ich finde das
toll dass wir hier ins Gespräch kommen
auch wenn wir ganz an vielen Punkten auf
man nicht Übereinkommen aber das müssen
wir wieder tun wir dürfen uns nicht
abschreiben gegenseitig und sagen ne der
ist asozial der ist unsolidarisch
sondern ich möchte euch verstehen und
ich hoffe dass wir als Gesellschaft
insgesamt wieder miteinander ja ins
Reine kommen sozusagen das ganz
interessant jetzt gab es ja schon
diverse Punkte wo ihr wirklich
diametral auseinander seid aber dein
Letzter Vortrag jessica hat dazu geführt
dass Grün relativ weit nach vorne
gegangen ist du hast nämlich davon
gesprochen es bringt nichts wenn wir uns
jetzt mit Häme übergießen und die einen
sind asozial die anderen sind sozial da
bist du nach vorne gegangen das hatte
ich überzeugt genau weil es ist der
Punkt den ich auch so sehe dass wir die
beiden Lager die sich jetzt ja so
herauskristallisieren wieder versuchen
müssen über den Dialog zusammenzuführen
und dass wir diese gesamte mit Emotionen
aufgeladenen Diskussionen die wir
tagtäglich draußen erleben einfach
wieder auf den nüchternen Boden bringen
und vor allem auch die ganzen Sachen
versachlichen an der nämlich wie wie
bringen wir das auf nüchternen Boden bei
Dingen wo man offenbar ganz
unterschiedlicherweise schwierig also es
gibt ja die sag mal die radikalen
Impfgegner die Wärme wahrscheinlich nie
erreichen egal mit irgendeinem
fachlichen Argument schon gar nicht mehr
und erst recht nicht mit irgendwelchen
Maßnahmen wie jetzt z.B 2G bin ich oder
jetzt irgendwelchen
lohnfortzahlungsgeschichten weil das
sind Dinge die werden die Leute in diese
Lage versetzen und sagen ja jetzt erst
recht also jetzt erst recht lasse ich
mich nicht impfen so aber es gibt ja wie
gesagt noch ein gewissen Anteil an
Leuten die Politik hat jetzt auch muss
man auch ganz klar sagen nicht geglänzt
dabei das ganze Problem wirklich zu
richtig zu kommunizieren auch in
mehreren Sprachen zu kommunizieren und
das sind denke ich noch Potenziale die
wir haben und da müssen wir einfach hin
könnte es sein Elke dass wir dass diese
Diskussion diese ganze Sendung
eigentlich obsolet ist wenn im willige
und im unwillige sich die Köpfe
einschlagen sondern dass man eher
diejenigen erreichen muss die einfach
noch nicht Zugang hatten zu einer
Spritze und dann mit wäre das Problem
vielleicht gelöst ich denke schon also
ich
bin der Meinung dass die Erreichbarkeit
der ungeimpften der Schlüssel ist und
aus der Pandemie rauszukommen und
wirklich in endemische Lage zu kommen
wenn wir genug geimpfte haben können wir
die wenigen die jetzt wirklich militant
gegen eine Impfung sich wehren wieder
besseren Wissens oder weil sie nicht
erreichbar sind dann kann man diejenigen
einfach
mittragen als Gesellschaft ich frage mal
ganz kurz euch wir empfindet ihr diese
Debatte spaltet eine solche Debatte
brauchen wir mehr sagen wir mal mehr
Empathie für impfungwillige würdet ihr
sagen das ganze ist hämisch aufgeladen
ist das eine sinnvolle Dialog den wir
hier auch hier führen schreibt uns gerne
in die Kommentare oder bevor wir jetzt
in die Kompromiss Runde kommen ich weiß
dass es wahnsinnig schwierig hier
überhaupt ein Kompromiss zu finden ich
schlage jetzt mal einen vor und danach
würde ich euch bitten in euren Gruppen
mal untereinander die Köpfe
zusammenzustecken um einen eigenen
Kompromissvorschlag zu konzipieren in
der Hoffnung dass sie es schafft die
anderen bisschen mehr zu euch zu ziehen
ich sag mal ein Kompromissvorschlag
erstes Ziel erste Prämisse unsere
Gesellschaft soll so inklusiv wie
möglich sein der Ausschluss von
ungeimpften sollte also nicht Ziel
sondern höchstens letztes Mittel sein
das heißt konkret
und da kommt jetzt die Einschränkung 3G
schlägt grundsätzlich 2G allerdings bei
risikobehafteten Veranstaltungen so habe
ich es formuliert also zum Beispiel
Festivals Clubs und so weiter müssen
ungeimpfte damit leben dass sie zum
Beispiel ein negativen PCR-Test bezahlen
und vorweisen können in welchem Zeitraum
wäre die Frage in einem absehbaren
Zeitraum nicht ein Leben lang ist das
ein Kompromissvorschlag wo ihr sagt ja
kann ich einen kleinen Schritt nach
vorne gehen
also nur zur Klärung diesen Fall haben
wir jetzt schon wir haben uns ja auch
als Clubs schon darauf eingerichtet
diese 2g-regelung durchzuführen und das
machen wir auch alle Clubs
3G aber das dritte g ist ein PCR-Test
also mehr dann das ist ja unser
Vorschlag genau das ist das ist ja es
ist euer Vorschlag den ihr macht er ist
aber nicht Realität momentan
der ist meine Ansicht nach auch nicht
realisierbar der PCR-Test braucht
zumindest auf dem Land wo ich auch wohne
zu lange bis er da ist um dann noch
gültig zu sein Gut in Berlin wäre das
vielleicht möglich das sind drei Stunden
Tests möglicherweise möglich fahre ich
an der nächsten Flughafen um dann drei
Rede man warum bewegst du dich nicht du
bist so die ersten zwei Sätze die du
gesagt hast waren hervorragend klar ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir zu einer
Unterscheidung kommen das ist ein Mittel
und es ist ein imperfektes Mittel über
alles was wir hier diskutieren und
niemand behauptet das wäre einen guter
oder schöner Umgang mit der Problematik
ich bin nicht ganz ich war nicht ganz
zufrieden mit einer Abgrenzung 3G 2G
naja wo wird das genau einsetzen du hast
jetzt von risikobehafteten
Veranstaltungen glaube ich gesprochen
das ist wieder ein sehr weiter Begriff
da könnten wir jetzt zum wahrscheinlich
wieder zwei Stunden darüber diskutieren
wo ist jetzt das Risiko oder ich
bestreite das gar nicht das nicht Clubs
auch risikoreicher sind als ein Einkauf
für mich einig aber an vielen anderen
Stellen sind wir uns wahrscheinlich
nicht sehen haben wieder eine andere
Lobby als Clubs das geht mir dann wieder
auf die Nerven wann werden die dann
anders sie hat's gesehen schwierig so
ein Kompromissvorschlag zu unterbreiten
jetzt seid ihr dran könnt ihr euch mal
unterhalten wie könntet ihr vielleicht
die anderen auf eure Seite ziehen merkt
euch euren Platz ungefähr wo ihr wart
und dann bitteschön
[Musik]
ja man sieht es schon es ist bei dieser
Fragestellung nicht gerade einfach eine
Kompromisslinie erstmal zu definieren
aber vielleicht habt ihr einen Vorschlag
wie würdet ihr diese beiden Parteien
näher aneinander bringen schreibt's mal
in die Kommentare wer weiß vielleicht
ist ja etwas fruchtbares dabei freue
mich drauf ist was willst du das
vertragen ja und selbst die Patienten
bei mir dies nicht Sauerstoffflasche
reinkommen haben eine Maske
wer will anfangen die Juristen
JuristInnen anfangen ja also wir sind
der Ansicht dass wir eine allmähliche
Aufhebung aller Maßnahmen beginnen
sollten und zwar jetzt allerdings nicht
sofort also nicht im Sinne von einem
Freedom Day wir sehen zwar also
zumindest ich sehe das juristisch als
gegeben dass man das jetzt sofort
eigentlich schon gestern hätte machen
müssen aber wir haben uns darauf
geeinigt dass wir das nicht jetzt sofort
machen würden sondern allmählich wie in
Dänemark zum Beispiel da haben die im
Anfang Juni mit der maskenpflicht da war
eine Impfquote bei knapp 25 Prozent
haben die die maskenpflicht aufgehoben
und sukzessive bis eben zum zum Freedom
Day der jetzt Anfang September war alle
Maßnahmen aufgehoben und wir appellieren
oder unsere Vorstellung wäre dass man
eine Risikogruppen bezogene Aufklärung
für die Impfung macht dass man weiß was
die Hauptrisikofaktoren für einen
schweren Verlauf sind gezielt diese
Gruppen anspricht um die zu gewinnen
weil wir eben nichts davon hielten
einfach alle jetzt also alle zu
behandeln als hätten alle das gleiche
Risiko denn das ist eben nicht so alle
ungeimpften darüber reden ich habe
versucht das zu verstehen also wir
adressieren explizit die ungeimpften und
dann aber die Risikogruppen unter den
Unterricht
ungegruppen und gleichzeitig eine
gestufte Aufhebung die Maßnahmen sind
aber nicht gekoppelt an eine Impfquote
insgesamt nein also der Abbau der
Maßnahme okay habt ihr das verstanden ja
deswegen bin ich zurück deswegen bist du
zurückgegangen kannst du noch mal
vielleicht in aller Kürze erklären warum
die
Aufklärung und das Belassen des
persönlichen Risikos nur für die
Risikogruppen bedeutet aber auch dass
ich die Risikogruppen bei denen die
Impfung leider Gottes nicht so gut wirkt
wie bei den normalen Menschen die kein
Risiko haben
ich die wieder alleine lasse das heißt
wenn ich keine entsprechende Impfquote
habe dann lasse ich die Leute mit einer
immuneffizienz dann lasse ich die Leute
mit einer Glukose mit einer
glucocoticoid also mit einer
Cortisontherapie dann lasse ich die
Leute die Krebs haben dann lasse ich die
Leute die eine Organtransplantation
haben und bei denen die Impfung einfach
unzureichend wirkt im Regen stehen das
heißt diese Leute können weiterhin nicht
am gesellschaftlichen Leben teilnehmen
für die ist es weiterhin gefährlich
obwohl sie geimpft sind Erik du hast
dich glaube ich nicht bewegt nicht
bewegt also es geht darum sehr neutral
also Maßnahmen nach und nach abzubauen
ja graduell auf jeden Fall graduell das
finde ich gut dass ihr das gesagt habt
dass das nicht sein kann oder nicht sein
es funktioniert nicht sondern wir müssen
das Stückchen für Stückchen machen auf
jeden Fall okay jetzt seid ihr dran wir
waren ehrlich gesagt erst ein bisschen
ratlos
gar nicht böse gemeint ratlos weil wir
uns glaube ich ehrlich bemühen wollten
Kompromissvorschlag zu machen und hoffen
dass wir dass wir in einem Punkt uns
zumindest im Ziel einig sind dass wir
glaube ich mehr oder weniger alle dafür
sind mehr Impfungen in der Gesellschaft
tut allen gut bzw hilft bei dem großen
Ziel aus der Pandemie rauszukommen und
möglichst viel Freiheit wieder zu
erlangen in welchen Schritten andere
Diskussion und deswegen glaube ich ist
unser Vorschlag dass wir gerne die
Energie der Diskussion darauf lenken
würden
wie wir mehr Menschen zur Impfung
kriegen von denen die erreichbar wären
und die die nicht erreichbar sind die
eben nicht
hat nicht gut funktioniert ich weiß ja
ich bin natürlich dafür dass man ins
Angebot weiter aufrecht erhält und
ich frage nur wie lange also wir reden
hier über die Verhältnismäßigkeit und
wir reden über den Zeitraum und wir
können uns darauf einlassen dass wir
sagen wir machen das über den Winter
noch mal mit Einschränkungen aber wenn
das nicht absehbar ist das dann auch bei
sinkenden Zahlen auch wieder sinkende
Maßnahmen stattfinden dann kommen wir
nicht zusammen wie ging es weniger um
Einschränkungen sondern mehr um
Kommunikation mit Angeboten auf jeden
Fall also volle Energie in diejenigen
die potenziell erreichbar sind mit einem
impfangebot also ich glaube das große
Stichwort war Solidarität die einen
verstehen unter Solidarität dass man
sich impfen lässt und dass man möglichst
noch die Leute die umkämpft sind
einschränkt und meine Solidarität fängt
jetzt an die Leute wieder zu integrieren
die wir außen vor gelassen haben mein
Ziel wäre das halt so schnell wie
möglich dieses Ziel zu erreichen und das
funktioniert halt leider mit einer
unproblem Maßnahme denke ich eher als
dieses Problem von ich der mein über 3G
lösen würden künstlich nie länger ziehen
einfach ich wünsche mir für die Zukunft
dass es ein Expertengremium gibt was
nicht aus reinen virologischer Sicht die
Pandemie betrachtet sondern alle Aspekte
dieser Pandemie mit hineinnimmt in
Gremium aus Psychologen Virologen
Sozialpädagogen ein runder Tisch an dem
diese Menschen gemeinsam diskutieren und
die Politik beraten und die Politik dann
auch bitte nicht beratungsresistent ist
das ist alles richtig meiner Meinung
nach hat es genau diese
interdisziplinäre breite
gesellschaftliche Auseinandersetzung
immer wieder gegeben ich halte das die
Beobachtung oder das Argument wir würden
ja nicht alle Aspekte
ja betrachten oder die hätten nicht eine
Stimme am Tisch sozusagen halte ich für
eine falsche Behauptung wir handeln sehr
komplex aus immer wieder die Ergebnisse
gefallen nicht jedem das ist auch völlig
in Ordnung insofern wäre mein Wunsch
eher dass viele Menschen sich noch
einmal ganz ehrlich hinterfragen und
reflektieren wo sie vielleicht doch sich
von dem Egoismus leiten lassen und das
auf den Prüfstand stellen und vielleicht
über ihren Schatten springen
lustig ich habe das Gefühl dass wir
immer so die Dinge sagen und jeder denkt
sondern ich meine dich mit deinem
Egoismus und ich denke ja ich meine dich
ich glaube ich kenne sehr sehr viele
Leute die egoistischer sind als du okay
ich kenne Dich gar nicht insofern
okay wir müssen ja auch keinen
Kompromiss finden ja gut ich denke bei
dem Thema war es abzusehen dass wir
keine einvernehmliche Lösung finden
werden auf der anderen Seite ist auch
klar geworden dass es sich lohnt
möglichst sachlich weiter um Kompromisse
zu ringen gerade bei diesen Themen die
so dermaßen emotional aufgeladen sind
wir brauchen euren Support hier könnt
ihr unseren Kanal abonnieren hier oben
findet ihr eine weitere Folge 13 Fragen
und hier ein weiteres Video zum Thema
tschüss